le rat a mauvaise réputation en milieu
rural il représente une menace au
cultures en ville c'est une vermine à
l'opposé le chien fait partie des
animaux les plus appréciés un compagnon
idéal une aide précieuse
lors d'un tremblement de terre le chien
sauve même des vies grâce à son millier
de types de récepteurs olfactifs il
détecte la présence de victimes
ensevelie sous les décombres
or le rat pourrait le remplacer plus
petit moins lourd il se faufile
facilement à travers les décombres
depuis l'été 2022 l'université de
l'agriculture à socoane en Tanzanie
entraîne des rats à titre de futurs
experts en recherche et sauvetage leur a
possède un atout un odorat encore plus
développé que celui du chien le rongeur
dispose de 1200 types de récepteurs
olfactifs 1% de son ADN est impliqué
dans la détection des odeurs avec cet
attirail le rat est capable d'identifier
la provenance d'une odeur en 50
millisecondes
quelle est l'origine de son frère
un peu comme Louis sa perception des
odeurs fonctionne en stéréo
des cellules de son bulbelfactif cette
région du cerveau qui reçoit les
informations collectées par les narines
réagissent différemment selon que
l'odeur provient de la narine gauche ou
de la narine droite
cette différence le guide vers la source
olfactive
le rat n'en est pas assez première
prouesses dans certains pays ravagés par
la guerre on l'utilise pour détecter la
présence de mines antipersonnelles
déposer dans un champ il renifle la
poudre exposive l'odeur du TNT
et cela même des années après que la
mine était enfouie